time time is a funny thing we have so
much of it and yet so little hey I'm
Darrin hard worker husband father one
taxpayer latte drinker
bookworm I'm just your average dude but
yeah sure I guess I made some pretty big
mistakes this moment right here this is
my first memory of time standing still I
have this theory about time why humans
perceive it differently in different
parts of their lives I think that when
were younger we appreciate the richness
of everything around us and when we grow
older themes seem dull more opaque when
we're children we experience every event
in our lives as something new and
amazing so is this why time seems to
move so slowly
[Music]
but then there came a point when
everything started to feel repetitive It
was as if the world started moving
around me and that was just along for
the ride
Friday's became Mondays and a blink of
an eye
summer turned into the first day of
school and Halloween Thanksgiving
Christmas year after year
[Music]
yeah everything is the same I wanted
more than this I want it out I got a
little something for you sure you know
what it is okay maybe this part was
pretty cool but everything else was too
dull
to normal
[Music]
[Music]
we should get there yes there were times
when I felt like I finally had that
feeling back again but I still felt
stuck time it's a mystery
my whole life I was blinded by the fact
that I needed to always be doing
something new and exciting to be able to
feel like I wasn't wasting time
[Music]
and this this moment right here is how
the story all began I've seen that look
of disappointment before from another
person who was so close to my heart
daring I know you're in a hurry for
meeting your mother and I'm proud of the
independent person that you are today
little story I was like he wants
everything change for me the best thing
in my life okay you can dream and you
know nobody's gonna stop you from doing
that but you're always gonna have that
feeling of being stuck nagging at you I
want you to think about what you've
already done and you need to be proud of
that because it's a lot when you start
thinking about them now the achievements
of now you'll always be happy
I'll let the time with people that I
care about move too fast but at that
moment looking at her face made me
realize I need to slow down
I chose to live the life that I have now
and I finally accepted that and I will
live to the best of my abilities